[Music]
hell-blade sin was sacrifice has made
video game news for a number of reasons
this week not the least of which is
because reviews are generally favorable
I'd say yeah Alessandro Phil are you
here at GameSpot review you can go check
out his review on GameSpot he liked it a
lot
he thinks the game does some really
great stuff and I agree I beat it Sunday
night I'm playing through it's it's
weird because looking at this this does
not you know the definition of indie is
always kind of morphing it's not people
misuse it all the time but this is an
independent studio Ninja Theory who
previously the last thing they did was
the DMC remake was that the last thing
yeah before that heavenly sword they did
have like character action combat games
and I think going into this a lot of
people thought they do the same thing
but this is more of a lot of people are
saying it's like a visual novel almost
like walking simulator ish with combat
elements and puzzle solving stuff I
thought the the visual novel not
comparison I guess that observation was
really interesting because like the
traditional idea of a visual novel is
usually like you know text on screen
character icon but I like bending that
definition a little bit and that's
definitely the vibe that I get starting
this game out I mean you're really like
I was listening very intently because I
didn't turn on subtitles cuz I'm dumb
and it really captured my attention
right from the very beginning yeah I
have a bunch of questions about this but
I do want to Pete you're like maybe
halfway through based on when I saw you
playing today oh really I mean six hours
no I little lesson halfway you're almost
at the halfway mark how many so is it
just those those two paths sorry yeah
now that I think of it you're less than
halfway so you beat those two and that
is like halfway gotcha umm yeah it's
cool cuz like you have and then you have
live-action stuff like this they have
really great they use Unreal Engine
actually back at GDC 2015 I think they
did a demo when I Tim Sweeney is that
correct
epic I see yeah yeah he went on stage to
show off the actor for this who actually
was the video editor who did other like
video marketing and in-game cutscene
editing yeah Tamim Antonio date and
Tonio nah days I think I'm correct
pronouncing it correctly he's at their
studio in Cambridge he they
her to help them out with the facial
capture and acting early on the process
telling her that she was just a stand-in
for that actor but they actually were
she was the actor and they didn't really
tell her until after but she didn't want
some jobs they kept her on so that is
who you see doing all this motion cap
what's the value of that not telling her
well I'm sorry it wasn't like the plan
right away they just they literally had
her as a stand-in and like huh this
could go somewhere because great job did
awesome yeah it's a tough character to
portray I mean yeah one of the other
huge aspects this game is that ninja
theory is pretty upfront with the fact
that they are portraying this girl who
has you know what we now call psychosis
although obviously this is uh I don't
even know what you want to call like
eighth ninth eighth century Celts
although when the Vikings came to Orkney
which is where this is the game is based
off like Orkney celts Germanic tribes
north of like Hadrian's Wall in England
when the Vikings kind of took over that
area the Vikings became the prevalent
tribes in the ninth century so this is
maybe even like early ninth century this
is all kind of just like boring
historical stuff but it's kind of
relevant because she's a Celtic part of
a celtic tribe she's a celtic warrior
there's cinema but the mythology that is
kind of paralleling her journey here is
all Norse yes or Odin Loki right here
they talk a lot about the the Northman
which I mean this is the kind of stuff
that I just can't get enough of so I was
already like so onboard and then you
have that added aspect of what I think a
lot of people would interpret as
schizophrenia and they're very up for I
mean like even the opening credits has
like mental health advisor which so it
was like that blend of things is just so
cool to me you don't see that a lot yeah
there's a trigger warning to begin the
game saying a lot of this could be bad
stuff for people who potentially like I
mean I mean psychosis can be a symptom
of a lot of things to be a system of
depression it could be a symptom of
bipolar disorder like really really bad
anxiety but like you said I think what
she would have is the closest to what we
call schizophrenia today but Ninja
Theory was quote careful not to label it
right but I appreciate ya and that's you
see the puzzles here in the war in the
real world I actually want to compare
these puzzles to another game but if I
said that I would actually kind of spoil
the other game
I'm not trying to be purposely elusive
but I don't know if you guys know I came
a timeout from last year so you're doing
these puzzles and part of the coolest
thing in my opinion and actually goups
you riot unofficial official games my
number one fan he tweeted me today for a
question the lobby's saying are you
talking about this games portrayal of
mental illness and I'm we're doing a
reboot house on an open episode I will
say I think it's it's really really
authentic and empathetic approach to
portraying mental illness are they
consulted a bunch people from University
of Cambridge psychiatrists and like
mental health experts I mean they were
like the first names in the credits yeah
yeah and like I said right after that
trigger warning said you can go to hell
blade help dot info and I thought it
would be like a game specifically for
the game but it's them just redirecting
a bunch of different people to
international suicide hotlines
depression outlets and whatnot so they
took it very seriously and it shows so
you see combat right here people are
calling me there's a question about
whether it's Dark Souls we'll get into
that but you see her she's addressing
the Cameron they used binaural audio
which kind of it this game is best play
with headphones yeah and you hear voices
from either side again that's part of
her psychosis you can hear voices
hallucinations are big but also the
delusion aspect of this game like people
with psychosis will start making
connections in the world that other
people see as coincidence and kind of be
paranoid about them in this game that's
how the puzzle come into place she sees
connections in the world that like
triggered this that it's kind of like
this hyper creativity and it's really I
think the game does a good job of
implementing that I feel I feel like two
minds about it because I think the idea
of finding those false connections and
making them seem real that's effective
but I'd like you saw me struggling with
one this morning I feel like it's in
certain cases drawn out to the point
where it's like hey I got it yeah you
don't need to be wasting my time making
me do this in ways where I'm like
folding in on myself trying to do it
like yeah you know so much what this
game does is great in the immediacy of
how effective it can be that I feel like
those things kind of slowed me down to
the point where I was like I'm no longer
engaging with this character I'm
engaging with puzzle design and that's
not what for the most part this game
seems to be doing or at least that's not
where its strengths sure but a man like
so I was playing in that section you saw
today and I noticed these little
glimmers of light like on a on a tree
and I thought oh that's weird maybe
that's like texture pop-in or something
like that yeah and they were so fleeting
they would like be there one second and
gone the next like when I tried to
actually focus on it when I did actually
get the chance to focus on it I realized
it was projected video of eyeballs
yeah really yeah so like it looks like
light because the pupil is so big and
there's only so much white of the eye
left on the video they're projecting
damn that it looks like something like
that but like even details that you
might not even consciously be aware of
are you sleeping into your head it's
just like it's it's like like you said
there's something we said you know apart
from what they're trying to do and
depict with this character I do think
the puzzle solving can be pretty
drawn-out and dry after you get it yeah
I think they do push it too far a little
bit gameplay wise I like it I got it
fits but it does kind of hurt the pacing
yeah the combat as well later on there's
a few kind of mechanics that you can
spam I was showing or I was telling you
about it it's one of those things where
once I discovered one thing to do gets a
specific enemy I was like damn I wish I
didn't know this I don't know if it was
an oversight on their part but it's so
it becomes repetitive when you figure
these things out but we can get more
into the combat I think the combat is
satisfying and functional but I don't
necessarily think it's fantastic
i I think it's functional like I would
give that I I mean like it's just so not
the point
to me where I just kind of considered it
like I think the the most notable thing
about the combat is the environment in
which it takes place is really haunting
at least from what I've played it's
really disturbing and that imagery is
really effective and so the fact that
I'm just kind of spamming one thing is
is not really what I'm thinking about
anyway and I'm kind of glad for that
like I don't want to have to think too
hard about the combat because the other
thing about sin you as a character is
that she's very she has so much fear in
her face when you see her and she's she
seems lost in a lot of ways and and I
think that's part of her character as
well that I think that the fact that I'm
just kind of like
I swear is is almost appropriate for her
like I don't mind it like I saw some
people on Twitter kind of being like the
combat really turned me off but I just
don't like if you're playing this game
for the combat then I think you're not
your stuff is flying over your head
you're not really looking at the right
things yeah there didn't seem to be I
have only played probably like an hour
two hours but there was no like tutorial
or explanation of really anything right
right and it leaves some things that you
can do up to you to discover beyond just
simply attacking and blocking like
combinations of inputs that you wouldn't
think yeah yeah combos for sure yeah
like I feel like the spamming is like a
result of that right like I'm I mean I'm
in it I'm gonna think of it I'm just
gonna like sorta that's mess around but
like that's nice here at least like
along the way you start realizing like
okay combos like yeah and even parrying
and stuff and like once you see that
then it almost you know the combat then
falls into that sort of like puzzly sort
of engagement where you're looking for
tells and you're trying to react as
quickly as possible in that sort of
thing
yeah DFW gamer on YouTube was saying
someone else was asking you saying the
combat is kind of like a mix between God
of War and Dark Souls it's limited to
the small areas in which you fight
though I forgot to mention that you
don't you can't just always swing your
sword send a while will literally pull
her sword out at specific combat areas
right once you know she you've killed
everybody and you're done with that wave
of enemies or boss which he'll cheat her
sword and then move on to the next kind
of story driven twenty minutes half hour
or puzzle-solving for the next toy
minutes half hour I guess we could ask
that so okay John Luke I'm sorry this is
out of order actually no no no okay I'll
go an order so Redfield on Twitter sorry
I'm looking at our run of show redfield
Twitter said how would you best describe
the overall flow or feel of gameplay I
know it's a tired method but what
contemporaries does it most compared to
so DFW gamer on YouTube just mentioned
the new god of war I believe he means
the upcoming one and that's actually the
first thing I thought of they're going
from that third-person comp or character
action like Devil May Cry almost that
ninja theory made to what the new God of
War looks like
over the shoulder melee combat as
opposed to just freestanding camera
I think that's an apt comparison I think
God of War looks like it might be a
little more in-depth but it does feel
weird because the cameras fixed over her
shoulder and you're fighting people
you're not like rotating the camera
sometimes anyway yeah yeah and the audio
figures in that because her voice will
say look out behind you that's really
cool too that's so cool unlike the fixed
camera also you always have a blind spot
with that like no matter what and I love
that because a lot of this game is about
perspective yeah visions yeah what you
see and what you don't see and I always
feel slightly unsafe which I like and
it's it's definitely it was at first I
was like this is weird like I'm not
usable yeah and I sorry Rob oh one more
thing
eighty-four Jester X before it
disappears off a shot on YouTube said
and surprised no one's mentioning
heavenly sword yeah it's it's similar
but that was more like Devil May Cry
like character action right I didn't
play it but yeah from what I understand
yeah it was not as like focused is this
game same developer ninja theory and
then people were mentioning Kai from
heavenly sword look so that like narco I
wonder if or sorry Kai from heavenly
sword looks a bit like Senate I wonder
if it's like the wood paintings like
Celtic tribes stuff you were gonna say
something yeah just on the combat like I
the little I played yesterday a lot last
night I had a really hard time with this
game like among the you know the the the
take on psychosis and like you know
really making you uncomfortable but like
I had a bug and like with the first
combat encounter that like you know
probably if not the most important
encounter where you're like kind of
allowed or like you have that freedom to
kind of see what the buttons do like oh
my god the camera got stuck in a fence
tonight like was blindly doing [ __ ] and
was stuck there for a while like I think
I even died there but like I don't know
there's something about that moment we
maybe just like in my own head with long
with other voices like yelling at me I
don't know that was really hard but I
just had a lot like a hard time getting
into it and I it people have been saying
this like this game is not for everyone
I will continue to play but it's just
intense yeah it's tough all the way
through like I it's just yeah it's
alright are to play it's a hard game to
explain like just because it kind of
it's also we'll get more into like the
Triple A versus India pricing model
stuff and also there's a massive thing
that I'm kind of hesitant to bring up
but I think it's in the public eye
enough that I'm not spoiling anything
anymore yeah it's it's tricky because
there's a really good discussion we had
with it and we don't know if it's a
legitimate thing or not yeah yet
essentially the way I think we can say
the game tells you that permadeath is a
thing yeah and the way that it handles
it is perhaps unusual perhaps by
circumstance or what we can talk about
it's right the beginning a game so I
think we can talk about what the game is
telling you right like and what we've
tried out yeah I mean essentially if so
you have this thing this this rot and if
you die enough times it'll slowly crawl
up your body until it eventually infects
your brain and you're dead
wipe your save file whatever you say
according to this screen that comes up
it says send away will succumb to the
rot and all your progress will be lost
I'm assuming if you wanted to avoid that
you could upload to the cloud yeah it's
the power of the cloud yes Alessandro
when he was reviewing it just for like
like pragmatism was trying it out and he
didn't affect him he died he purposely
died like how many times like he was
like multiple times I'm saying he died a
bond and there's and there's videos on
YouTube of people pushing it to like I
think 50 deaths yeah so I think it's
another guy enough.we but then like
ninja theories saying no it's a thing I
think that's so I'm pretty sure that's
the truth
would I that they said that like PR
responded to someone he said like oh
it's probably a bug yeah
what I heard was that it's like there
are many different ways you can dungeons
in this game right and there are
different areas that can and cannot
facilitate to it so like there was one
area I won't tell you what I heard that
it's a it's a really tough area but it's
not it's just like a traversal aspect
yeah you can and you can dive based on
fireman I fell off a branch yeah today I
think think about it like from a design
point like you wouldn't want to
implement that there in that you don't
want to discourage someone who just
can't get their mind around it right
potential intentially like initially but
I think like this game takes enough
risks that I wouldn't be surprised if
they took a just do it
yeah yeah this game they do a lot of
things I mean putting we talked about
putting psychosis at the center of in
terms of gameplay and the
characterization of being upfront about
it is one thing but and then you get
into I mean yeah like the guy who was
dying he was dying in a fight I did it
50 times right yeah so but so the rot
was growing up my arm but I think it got
to like my shoulder before I finished
because I was playing on the auto
difficulties got like a resonable for
--is-- auto scaling the better you do
the harder will get but then you can
also put easy medium hard or whatever I
do you want to say like regardless of
whether it's true I think creating that
tension is cool like I think the idea of
the finality of it and I mean talking
about the combat and how people have
mixed feelings with the combat I think
part of the my my impulse to spam was
being like oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] yeah
and I think that even if it's not true
even if the game is telling you this
because I mean this is an unreliable
narrator right this is a this is a story
with somebody who doesn't always see
things as they are
oh and here's voices that aren't there
and so I mean I think regardless of
whether it actually happens or not it's
a cool thing to introduce that
introduces another layer of tension
besides the voice in one ear and the
Horwich chanting ahead of you and the
the you know dead bodies hanging from
trees let's it it creates another
dimension to it and I think I I mean I
know a lot of people are mad about it
for some reason but I think it's it's
interesting irrational fear irrational
like dread and growing despair is huge
their character and it kind of makes you
feel the way to which is well also like
courageous I mean even for if you don't
have something as Extreme as psychosis
like just like day-to-day anxiety is
like just the feeling of being like
there's danger around the corner like
your body being like bit beware and
you're being like no body there's no
danger in your body but what if you died
right now what if a stranger wants to
talk to you and has a question and says
hi yeah what is it like that
so that's something bad happening to me
and you're talking to me affected even
in the chat right now the twitch chat as
we're really and says GameSpot
apparently you have to die in several
different places for the permit earth to
work and then a bad player said perma
death was disproven so I don't it's it's
unclear and I think I'm that first
theory is curious to me but again that
would seem to not fall in line with what
the game is telling you mm-hmm I think
this is really interesting for ninja
theory because they're at a crossroads
where they can say all right guys
everyone thinks that this thing is one
lap Tyler yeah like they can either
confirm that they are as clever as
everyone thinks or say actually we
screwed up but thanks for thinking of us
and that permadeath yeah I I don't know
if it's what you're saying I would love
for them to just stick their guns back
no it can happen don't [ __ ] that's
kind don't test but I know what I'm
saying but they have to but if the
question posed to them is why does this
video why is there so much proof that it
doesn't happen yeah what do they say to
that yeah like it's either you're not
doing it right
which then I'd say then you didn't
explain it properly or it was a bug or
it doesn't happen or failure isn't that
what you think where it's all case study
there's interested to like very least
like we're talking about it now we have
no idea so people playing the game
really like [ __ ] I don't know if it's
gonna happen if I replay the game I'd
I'd still it would still even unless it
was completely disproven and they said
something I would still go into the game
if I replayed it and be like kind of
uneasy if I played on the hard happen to
be yeah I think we can segue into the
next part of this topic which is the
triple a double a because I really want
to talk about how incredible this game
looks mm-hmm the production qualities
are that which we we we don't see very
often like I often think of middle your
solid 5 is having some of the best
character modeling animation lighting
and camera work and seeing composition
out there for games specifically because
games are sort of a bit behind Hollywood
but this takes things to a level that is
so that makes you feel such a personal
connection of the carrot
and everything is so unreal but real
like it's it's the lighting it's the
texture work it's the animations it's
it's all there and I can't think of
another video game that at the best
moments of hell-blade that looks as good
as hell-blade yes domina
I will say that I expected the dead
bodies to be a little have more detail
it is about yes affecting them a little
too closely and they looked kind of like
the corpses look like a like a ps2 HD
upgrade for some reason the corpses
aren't but don't look as good as
everything else but like oh my god just
being in the like the forest and like I
was getting distracted just looking
around well it's these moments - yeah
like this is the sort of thing where I
like I can't I is its CG right but I
could you could tell me it's not and I'd
say wow that was pretty good
post-processed effect I mean and they
also have FMV I don't think I've seen
any yet myself but then don't they it's
that guy it's well guy that's fades in
and talks to you several characters
later on you combine that and they're so
like you know a long side like effects
and like you know neat composition that
it's not so Blaine you know what I mean
it's not like here's a cutscene now oh
yeah everything is so seamless and
consistent right like there I don't
think there are the only loading times
as or if you like die ray like I don't
know it's yeah and that's very important
to the experience of being on this
journey with someone like yeah it's a
very different beast than shadow of war
but the same thing applies like if
you're trying to invest a character in
this fantasy they need to have as few
barriers as possible to engage with it
and be a part of it and this game for
the most part ensures that that's the
case all the time it's it's interesting
that lawbreakers came out the same day
because oh no sorry to go back to
pricing stuff triple-a yeah play like 30
now they're both $30 right and you know
like it's a six to eight hour game I
think I beat in about six hours it felt
longer than that because of the
oppression of the story but I do think
that that's an interesting precedent
it's always like what do we why do we
price game $60 by default if like you
know it's gonna be this long or they're
gonna be this much to do or it's gonna
be you know this much replay value it's
always kind of this gray area and it
kind of hopefully sets an interesting
precedent
for that conversation of the future with
these this level of production in games
no publisher would have fun of this game
sure I can't imagine anyone brought this
to it like an EA or Warner Brothers and
they'd be like yeah we wanted a dark and
brooding pretty you know examination
what kind of DLC you got planned for
that like I know this is exactly this
[ __ ] I do like like this game like you
could have told me like Oh Cali they
made a game specifically for you to
enjoy I'd be like oh yeah sorry I'll
give you some money for that sorry
nobody funded this like I would believe
you if you said like they had a really
hard time getting people to want it
because it just is it's so specific and
I think also so relatable it's I think
there's a sense of authorship even
though you couldn't credit it to maybe
one person or another but it feels like
there's a vision here that is just it's
it's allowed to do everything that the
people behind it want it to do and it
reminds me of something like the Last
Guardian in terms of that that feeling
of playing a game that is more than just
a product to sit on a shelf to sell to
gamers and right like this is in a sense
of work of art that that yeah is
authoritative and what it's trying to do
absolutely John Luke I am gonna jump
skip over one question go back to it
sorry but I do have a question in
regards to this kind of triple-a model
luigi wagner who has submitted a few
questions a lobby throughout the months
we've been going thank you very much
could help late production models signal
the birth of a new tier of games as in
smaller triple A's that aren't
constantly worrying about action they
would kind of covered that but I think
that is a very relevant question for
this game and it's one that'll be
examined on GameSpot we've got something
coming up cool oh yeah yeah specifically
my holiday right and and this topic as
well about birthing a new category if
you will cool yeah
luigi wagner thank you again and then
i'm gonna go back to it one more
question kind of that i skipped over
about the combat joseph lee on twitter
said thinking about buying hell-blade
but heard the combat is watered down
souls repetitive and the big pro is the
story thoughts I think Dark Souls is
just is a
a bad comparison I think that's the kind
of knee-jerk reaction to like dodge and
blocking based melee combat um no I
think this is very different I mean
those those elements are there and maybe
like the fact that they don't tutorial
everything and you kind of figure out a
few things yourself that I might factor
into the Dark Souls comparison yeah but
it's I mean as someone who sucks at dark
souls I think I can sort of maybe speak
a little bit to the different levels of
challenge that exist like Dark Souls is
in a sense meant to be a game that you
you kind of need to like fail a few
times before you really understand what
it is you need to do and this game yeah
failure is pretty hard you don't get
punished for not being right the first
second or even third time yeah so it's
not as demanding and I think that's
really more the souls thing it's not
punishing it can be yeah Joseph Lee
thank you for your question Redfield
luigi wagner as well
anything else inhale play before we go
on to lawbreakers yeah we're headphones
for sure yeah there were some freaky
moments in the best way we're it's like
I think one of the characters like
talking to you like from right here to
left and it just it felt like he was
legitimately pacing in the back of your
head which is literally what they did
during the recording sessions did you
there's a cool really cool feature on
the main menu of the game that you can
why the binaural like audio capture
device literally as this black cylinder
with fake plastic ears on the side that
actually captures sound through the
contours of a human ear oh yes and I
don't like ya lunge at it and kind of
circle it it's really cool to watch yeah
I missed that I missed the tour was just
I was like woo corpses if I can give any
practical advice it'd be just sit close
to a monitor when you're playing it cuz
having the headphones then having just
your view only be this game not like on
a couch like 15 feet away I me being
having that right in front of my face
like a foot away also helped are right
that would that I mean that could be
potentially date like I would back out a
lot yes VR games must use similar audio
or maybe they well they use similar yeah
there's some games that use similar
audio techniques and VR is actually
being used at USC to treatment things
like mental illness and PTSD yes
and it affects like stuff like this is
bad but it can also it's potentially bad
when bumming yes when used with the
proper direction very effective yeah
treating people one minor no not to get
heavy but yeah this game is super like
with the psychosis aspects and
everything the trigger warning is kind
of essential at the beginning it is a
tough game to get through especially if
you've seen this stuff up close all the
stuff [ __ ] sucks to deal with but I
do strongly advocate trying this game
out because it's a very empathetic and
very understanding and very you know
frankly authentic portrayal of this kind
of stuff and the fact that like this
young medium is doing it so well as
opposed to like you know you have movies
like some of my favorite ones deal of
stuff silver lines play about
punch-drunk love melancholia that stuff
all touches on it but you know not just
for a video game but for any kind of
entertainment or art form this is a
really really powerful portrayal it's
really nice to see something about
mental illness and some of my favorite
depictions or but I wouldn't say
favorite but the the most important ones
to me have been in games but it's just
nice to see it not portrayed as being
crazy it's it is very empathetic and for
comic relief yeah there's no like ha
she's right Domon weird you know like
which does sometimes happen in other in
other stories about mental illness and
so it it's I mean exercise caution of
course if it's something that you think
will be difficult for you but I think
it's it's worth experiencing
[Music]